this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
wednesday the 15th of the month the
halfway boy
the joint is brought to you by my
favorite manscape
thanks to manscape everything goes down
the drain crabs your disgusting pubic
hair your [__] hair thank god thank
[__] god but i'll tell you what you
got to try that new platinum package
it's like the greatest hits collection
the lawnmower 4.0
with the special blade so you don't cut
your [__] nut sack a spotlight so if
you decide to shave in the dark you
don't nick your [__] helmet or
[__] cut your little uncircumcised
skin off your dick like me
because it's waterproof the weed whacker
the nose and the air trimmer keeps your
holes safe while you clean up and
they're gonna send you the crop
preserver the crop reviver the ultra
premium collection of the body wash
shampoo
deodorant so you could smell good from
head to toe after you shave your [__]
monkey you understand me it's that time
[__] it's june and you're still
walking around with the wolfman sun
wrapped around your dick and your ass
smells like vinegar it's time i'm gonna
give you 20 off plus free shipping with
code joey at
manscape.com again
20 off and free shipping
so you don't look like a [__] baboots
anymore with code joey at manscape.com
i thank you manscaped you your
girlfriend thanks you your [__]
grandmother thanks you but most
important your balls will thank you the
joint is also brought to you by cbd lion
in the world of cbd
there's nobody nobody better than the
lion go to cbdlion.com
read the third party lab results
if there's something you like jump on it
i'm going to give you 20 off your first
order delivered right to your house with
code joey joint or church it's that easy
joey joined the church
20 off the liberty house the cbd ball
the [__] delta eight tincture they
got delta eight gummies that'll make
your [__] eyeballs spin in your head
plus i'm giving you 20 over take a
chance columbus did
cbd lion
ko joey get 20 off delivered right to
your house read the third party lab
results let's get this [__]
party started jack
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
do
what it is you bad [__]
wednesday the 15th we're at the halfway
part of the [__] month already where
did it go
we were just in ac the third and the
[__] fourth anyway it's a beautiful
[__] day to be alive
i think tomorrow night i'll be down at
uncle vinnie's if they let me go down
there on a thursday you know like i said
i'm doing my little [__] uh thursday
sets to keep this [__] [__] alive
i'm a little [__] up today i just hit
the vapor pen and it hit me a little
hard i hadn't gotten high all day so i
hit the vapor pen just as a pass-through
and it [__] zocked me in my feet
there
uh sometimes these vapers are getting a
lot stronger than what they were making
them a long time ago i mean i don't
really [__] with the vapors that much
abx sends me some [__] uh
vape cartridges and the other card the
live resin ones and
i don't really smoke them a lot in fact
i lost my live resin thing i've lost
both of them i had two of them i fixed
them i charged them i take them out for
a softball game or something
i do this and then they pop up like a
month later i wash them you know
who the [__] knows you get high that's
why i hated those double barrel shotguns
when i was a kid you know do coke they
were tremendous it was a straw with two
little things connected to the straw you
put it in the bag and did it but then
you sat on it a lot how an hour later so
it all sucks all that [__] sucks i just
stick to [__] joints and pipes today
we're going to talk to ali sadiq a
friend of mine
out of houston great comic doing a great
[__] job and i watch this guy listen
as a [__] comic i have my favorites
you know i like my bill birds i like my
rogans
but i watch a lot of young guys you know
i like i watch a lot of the guys guys
that are coming up you know i really
like alisa deek
i like what he's doing
i really like what josh wolf
[Music]
has been doing
since the pandemic these guys uh you
know uh ryan sickler
became a regular at the store since the
pandemic and is doing [__] great
things you know
it's great to see rachel woodson you
know it's great to see carmen morales
with a special
it's great to see fluffy [__] sellout
two
nights at dodger stadium you know i
follow all these things guys you might
not think i do but these are my friends
and these are people that i watched work
hard and break their [__] humps
and i see them getting little success
and it [__] makes my dick hard these
guys that you know when i lived in l.a
the big thing was the special
it's so weird as
individuals
when we get caught up on something like
for years it was the store
i would talk to young comics that moved
to la and they would go mike
my dream goal is to be at the store but
they would chomp at the bit so much over
the store the store the store that they
were missing the big picture guys we
were missing the big picture it's not
about the store it's about getting on
stage the store is going to be there
forever
the improv is going to be there forever
and the last factor is going to be there
forever
but a lot of guys would come to l.a and
if they didn't get into the store
it was a big [__] it was a big like
failure it's not a failure
you were there at the wrong time you
know and that's with a lot of things in
life and then it became the the netflix
special and the special you know hbo was
giving them to all the guys so netflix
opened up this streaming service and
they blew up people like ali wong and
tom segura and dane cook and bill burr
and help solidify them as stand-ups and
that was great but not everybody was
getting them
you know how would you feel if if
[__] all your friends had specials
and a guy like bobby lee that's been on
mad tv [__] store regular since
[__] jesus left chicago with me
i mean bobby lee has done everything he
couldn't get a netflix special
so you get bobby lee's experience and
he's a a great comic so he wouldn't
chomp at the bit like i'm then i'm not
getting a netflix special but people
actually do but what's happened over the
years are
there's comics like shane gillis you
know jimmy florentine
ari shot his specialist last week guys
those specials are getting shot and
they're going up on youtube
and you gotta applaud those guys you
don't look at them any less you don't
say well netflix didn't give him a
special he's not a funny comic no you
don't know the politics of what's going
on
he might be with an agent that netflix
don't like there's a thousand things
that are going on that you don't know
about so
when somebody puts a special up on
youtube for free that's a [__] gift
that you know you watch it you support
it
they have a button now on youtube that
you could vol you can donate money throw
a 10 at them it cost them 100 grand to
set all the cameras up and to get people
and editing and all that [__] you know
these guys you gotta applaud them
because they're not waiting on somebody
to [__] choose them oh my god we love
what you bring no i ain't bringing
nothing to your network you know what
i'm doing i'm gonna tape it myself i'm
going to own it myself
and i'm going to [__] put it on
youtube or any other platform that will
leave it on there for free i don't even
care about money
that's what a com when a comic sends
that message he's telling you that he
don't give a [__] he just wants you to
laugh while the other comics
are sitting there going well netflix
only offered me a quarter of a million
dollars boo hoo
and then you got other comics like hey
man i just want to get my [__]
material out there jay larson
there's been so many comics that have
done that and i applaud them
you know and i gotta be honest with you
youtube
everybody's got youtube
what's the
what's the [__] stigmata everybody's
got youtube
so [__] it if you i told young comics
for years listen
not right away but when you get the ball
going
if you put up a 10 minute clip a six
minute clip
every 10 weeks let's just say a six
minute clip every se ten weeks
can you imagine what you're gonna have
at the end of five years on your page
people sit at work all day people
working from home what do you think
they're doing they think they're oh my
god i gotta get the deadline they do a
little
bit and they throw on a billboard
special they do a little bit and they
throw on the yamaneika special they do a
little bit
they throw on a rogan podcast they do a
little bit they throw on a different who
the [__] knows but not everybody's
giving a hundred percent
you know as a telemarketer
you know when people always pick up the
phone you don't call people at six
o'clock at night when they're at home
you call them at work
because they're getting paid
they'll [__] do anything when they're
at work to throw them off work
and that's where you're special that's
where your skit
that's where your podcast that's what
whatever you're trying to put out is
going to get viewed when i got into
comedy our views were from 8 to 11. if
we didn't book a recurring
show or we didn't book a
it wasn't our show we didn't get a guest
star on the show you would never see us
that's not the case anymore you could
wake up at six in the morning eat a
[__] bowl of grape golden graham
smoke a joint
and watch skits all [__] day now
that's that's available to you stand up
whatever the [__] you're into podcast so
do me a favor when you see these guys
support them you know jimmy florentine
all these guys that are shooting their
specials and putting them up i give them
all the love in the world because the
message they're sending is they ain't
waiting on anybody
they ain't waiting on somebody to judge
their funniness whether they're funny or
not whether
using them will get chris rock to do one
because they have the same you know i'm
saying like a lot of guys are top heavy
so they have a guy like mike and they'll
go
listen if you give mike a special i'm
sure i'll talk to [__] dane cook
about a special
and you know make sure and then the
people give mike a special people sit
there going how did mike say that
special well he's got a great [__]
manager and a great agent so there's a
thousand reasons why
don't judge these comics for it and then
we got our lisa deak at lisa deacon and
i have
i love our lisa deacon more than a lot
of other comics because we both share a
[__] distinction
of getting sidetracked with a little
time in the state pen you know now you
can be ashamed of that or you could take
that and run with it sort of like what i
did i was ashamed of it i wasn't raised
to be a [__] criminal i enjoy it i
like stealing and snorting coke and you
know but it's not what you could [__]
do forever i'm not gonna sit here and
lie to you but
when you do uh
when you do a stint in prison your world
gets turned around and you're told that
you never amount to anything and if you
were ever told you were an amount to
anything that stint in prison solidifies
it so it's tough to get yourself out of
that meant it's tough to get yourself
out of a hole of being a felon never
mind when you haven't told yourself that
you're not a felon
so i've i always have a
softer spot in my heart
for guys that have been in jail
and that uh
have turned their life around like i did
it's not about the comedy it's not about
the storytelling it's not about my wife
it's that i turned my life around and
i'm very proud of that and now without
further ado
my main man mr ali sadiq and listen
we're going straight into ads after this
so enjoy our lisa deak
and we'll see you [__] monday
tip top magoo jack love you stay black
[Music]
what's up g-money
what's good my brother
welcome to the [__] joint on a
beautiful wednesday afternoon what's
happening baby
hey um
getting ready for life
that's all i can say all day just
getting ready for life what's been going
on over there in houston talk to me
um
i'm on the radio every day so i'm i'm
trapped in a bowl of
radio kids road radio kids road i don't
even know
if somebody asked me
a nuclear
a nuclear explosion happened
i wouldn't know about it in this site
unless they told me on the radio
right what radio are you on what station
are you down there
um magic 102
um
kbxx
102.1
every morning
um afternoon drive
[__] good that's pretty good a little
hustle there bet in the podcast you
spend the oldies
um
yeah from anywhere from the the
late 80s to um
[Music]
mid let me say mid-2000s
all right
never since the [__] pandemic came on
i'm gonna pay who i got into big time
like i didn't know how strong they were
the temptations
oh
[Music]
the temptation's very very strong that's
a strong
strong
musically
[__] you know motown people talk
about all the bands that motown produced
but they never talk about like when you
hear diana ross uh
you know keep me hanging on that [__]
guitar whatever that brother is
man little constant little [__] diddy
i mean it's just
people had no idea the power of [__]
motown
you you had to watch um
the documentary that they have
on motown
uh
about the brothers the whatever brothers
it's been on show time for a few years
with quincy jones yes
he missed smoking robinson and man
like marvin gaye was such a tremendous
part of the motown sign him and smokey
robinson
man
that was
that was phenomenal i could only imagine
when you hear even the first two as
as people gonna [__] hate this
when you listen to the first jackson
five albums
musically they're [__] phenomenal
those albums you know like the in-house
band they had could do it all
they could do [__] anything
and they could do it because the
jacksons could actually play i mean i
went to go see tito one time just tito
by himself
man tito is a bad bass player that's a
bad dude man
it
man
tito jackson by himself
and he looked royal at the time like man
this is royalty like
insane
but back to the temptations and i hate
to say something like this
they had equal or the same power as led
zeppelin
oh my god their [__] music runs deep
their albums are [__] phenomenal just
david ruffin
eddie kendrick's just david ruffin's
voice has always blown me the [__] away
every time that movie's on vh1 i watch
it and i know 20 [__] that
watch it from dean delray that's one of
dean delray's favorite [__] movies we
talk about it all the time the
temptation movie is [__] phenomenal
five hours on vh1
every black actor that's ever [__]
performed except billy dee williams and
a couple of them
they had so many brothers in that
temptation
[__] great band so it's great that
you're playing that there's a i'm
serious
there's a thing called soul town
yes
let me tell you something about the host
of so town that [__]
has so much knowledge that brother has
so much
i've heard him talk about [__] led
zeppelin on soul town man soul town from
first right x in radio is incredible
from
from 46 to 50
that my just in between it was soul time
comes on i think it's 46-47 46-47 and
i'm i'm a studio 54 dude too
i'll play that [__] every once in a
while they go off on studio not a lot
they play that stupid [__] but
every sunday night if you catch like
jelly bean or one of those dj's they go
[__] off on there and the podcast
they have on studio 54 they got some gay
[__] that come on there miley
shearer
and the other one sundays at four
o'clock
if you want to hear some and listen the
first ten minutes
it's either on or off
like so you'll know
like if they got like this is a doorman
from studio 54 and he's like oh my god
them the knights were magical vaseline
was flying through the air dumb crazy
[__] i'm telling you you got to
listen to those podcasts ali you will go
what the [__]
what are these white people doing the
studio 54. this is [__] crazy bananas
they were bananas at that time i watched
the documentary i was like
cocaine in the vents
like
really
this is just
blowing cocaine in the club just wow
like
on the tables getting your dick sucked
in the woman's bathroom sex and the
woman's bathroom
i went lunch time to steal 54. i walked
into the woman's bathroom there was 200
men snorting coke
these people who are pissed off about
the [__] bathrooms and [__] what if my
son goes into a bathroom oh [__]
how many men's how many opposite [__]
gender bathrooms did you go into snork
coke in the 80s now you want to get mad
at some boy with a skirt on and [__]
what the [__] is going on with these
[__] how many bathrooms i snort
coke and it's funny
did you catch that laker show
on hbo max yes the winning game the
winning game [__] tremendous i knew
you loved it but
i was thinking about you one night
because they were talking about david
thompson
remember like episode eight they're like
we gotta figure out how to cover
thompson
the knicks figured out they took that
[__] studio 54 game a bag of
coke he fell down the stairs
that [__] wasn't able to play
against the knicks that 48 inch vertical
leap was no good that [__] fell
down the stairs the studio do you know
he tried to sue studio 54
he said go wikipedia david thompson that
[__] fell down with a bag of
coke at studio down the front of the
stairs
and then he tried to sue studio and [__]
but by that time the next one they
didn't give a frenchman's [__]
so you know
the that must have been what the rockets
did
one year they was playing the lakers
and
they were they wanted to win that game
battle they did james worthy is not
playing
he's not but nobody knows what james
worth is james worley is in the harris
county jail
he got caught in the roll with some
prostitutes
and
and man wrestle james where james worthy
comes
to
the game in the third quarter
and light the goddamn rock is up for 23
points
that [__] was good that [__] still
didn't work babe i'm throwing these
arrested his ass still came out third
quarter and final rock in the start
how's the comedy treating you my brother
what's been going on in the world since
the pandemic
man since the pandemic i recorded a
couple of albums i
i did an hour um
on uh epics
and then i then i um recorded an hour
special
and man just been on the road but the
plan didn't slow me down a little bit
but other than that i've just been on
the road man just trying to put out a a
good product and trying to do
the best shows and
swap stories with my friends and you
know you know the living the life the
life of a comic
living comfortable i admire you man
because i
since the pandemic started you have
become
the king of houston and [__] you know
moses malone passed
you said i'm taking that [__]
torch and i see you at the improv doing
your games you know doing your [__]
shows and your residency there and i
know you called me one time
to come down and do a showy i wasn't a
proper mindset but
it's really [__] great to see you
josh wolf i've i've seen a lot of people
that have taken to this pandemic
and it made them grow as a comic i'm a
[__] old man i i don't give a [__]
you know i'll do my spots here and there
but it's good to see your young guys
just
picking up where you left off hey they
don't want to give me a special
i shoot my own [__] special i
was looking through your stuff you got a
couple albums on there you got a couple
things that you're doing this is called
what no-hold grudges or
i hold grudges or whatever yeah
this is the domino thing okay because
there's two of them that came out seven
hours ago one came out 22 hours ago i
don't know
yeah
that came out three days ago you're
worse than dave chappelle [__]
you got 10 specials
yeah man um
so this the domino effect
is um
i released it on may 19th
it's um we had a a million
a million plus now views
it's um
it's a
great i think it's a really good piece
of work it's just my life story between
the ages of 10 to 15
so i have um
16 to 19 to go
to um before i got busted
so i'm just you know putting these these
stories in in order
and
you know just trying to be the best
storyteller that i've you know i could
be trying to you know get up there with
with you and colin and cosby
you know y'all the best
at what y'all do so i'm just trying to
be in the running
it's crazy how much
storytelling has taken over our lives
since we did re show
because the response was so [__]
positive from hari's show i tell ari all
the time
i don't need a [__] special ari gave
me the best specials i could do that was
the best work i ever did those
storytelling shows forget my specials
and it it all sucked
storytelling for me was
ari you know ari brought that up
at the right time and if anybody
benefited from that the most it's you
and i
yeah we really found our [__]
niche which is uh
it's very rough to find in comedy
sometimes
i started out as rodney dangerfield you
know i mean i'm not gonna lie to you i
was a cross between rodney and
and uh andrew and over the years you
find that extra muscle you have by
performing by going out there you know
you think you're gonna be good at the
armbar but you're really good at the
kimura so it's like i gotta throw
jiu-jitsu into it
because it's so weird we keep working on
this type type of comment also this
other type of comedy creeps up and we're
really good at that type of comedy
so now we gotta figure out all three
worlds and that's what you and i have
done you're doing a phenomenal job
brother
and uh
it's it's really it inspires me and it
makes me believe that
what
my original belief was for this podcast
and for the word i was trying to spread
with the podcast
people give up man
people give up in their lives for some
reason or another
i never gave up i don't know if it was
going to prison i don't know if i think
that my whole life was
about me overshadowing that person that
went to prison because deep down inside
i am very ashamed of that if you know
how i was raised and how what i was
raised to do or to be it wasn't to end
up in [__] jail and i know your
mother did a good job and you that
wasn't
her plan with you so
we ended up there we made a mistake and
now i mean i see it with you you're a
great young man you're a [__]
you're an icon to the african-american
community because what you bring you did
not lay down you did not
let them tell you how your life was
going to be run that you're going to be
a nobody they told me to we're going to
be nobodies they tried to make a sign of
paperwork to give our lives away to
disability because they said that we're
disabled
because we're felons people aren't going
to look at us the same
this is a great thing that we've done
and whenever i feel down which i did for
a year
i always thought of that i thought of
that [__] the comedy [__] anything else
it was what
i did after getting locked up and i was
a dog i was on my way to end up in
prison again
this just became stronger than my desire
to go back to prison and that's what i
see with you you never get locked up
again you're never getting the ticket
again you're never hitting somebody in
the head with a hammer again
because you know
you've seen the other side you learn the
control
i mean you ain't gonna let a
[__] step up on you
but you're not gonna go out of your way
to end up in jail number because you
love prison i mean you love comedy you
love your children
i'm [__] ecstatic about this radio
show you're doing about to call in and
[__] and
spit the [__]
spend some [__] you know i love all
that funky [__] so
man
it's always a pleasure man because you
know
we
we some of those individuals that came
out in some of the worst situations
and changed without all of the
[Music]
without the fan fails changing you know
some people change because they have to
do it because they in front of people
but when you when you self motivated
to
change your life and and be in a better
position because because you are
one of those people who not just
love what you doing you love yourself
you learn to love yourself a lot more
you know and and
at times i was very self-destructive in
in so many ways when i was
out doing things and late and allowing
people to puppeteer me
pushing my buttons you know i got a
trigger and like man i don't know i'm
not i'm not pinocchio i don't have no
geppetto that just got me on this string
or anytime anytime they want me to get
mad i'm mad
i'm like i'm cool man um
so
i appreciate that man that means a lot
coming from somebody
out of the same
disposition that we came from it's the
truth listen i'm a minority you're a
minority
you have to add your statistics of what
the percentage of failure is what the
percentage of
you know people coming out from that
what are the odds when i see a black
doctor i go how the [__] did he do it
you know what i'm saying when i see
a [__] you know because
we were put into drugs whatever drugs
came into our lives nobody made them do
nobody made us do anything
we made a mistake
that's it
like the people that are getting
canceled today they made a mistake
and it wasn't for you to cancel them or
to shut them down or for them to live in
their house with the shades drawn for
two years
you don't have that power to do that a
judge did that to you and me we had a
decision to stay in you know when you go
in there man everybody's comparing
colleges i went to this jail i went to
the and everybody's like excited hey but
[__] that i'll beat that jail i went to
jail in harlem and also ah and you're
like that's what life is
i don't want to do a prison tour
my mother [__] spit me out her [__]
for me to do a [__] prison tour
or for me to [__] be on probation
she spit me out there to hit somebody in
the head with a hammer if they
disrespect me or something like that but
that that wasn't what the this plan was
so i think all my life for the last
since 1990 i've been fighting the stigma
of
being a [__] felon
yeah and i put it on my sleeve i'm not
hiding it for money but i'm not ashamed
of what i did it's like a hitch in the
army it builds [__] character and i
proved it and we proved what
what jail does for you if you let it
take its course
because what we did they don't teach you
in there there's no class for what we
did
you know
they got classes for when you get out
this is how you do your checking account
[__]
i didn't even had a checking account
when i got out i had i had never had
over 22 dollars in my atm card i had to
call my wife every day put a 20 in that
[__] so i could smoke some weed
i don't even know what people are
talking about
but that's
i see you on stage
i saw you that day
doing the instagram live with yamaneka i
was [__] dying at the baseball field
you know and i'm looking at you
with all the negative [__] in the world
with all the black lives matter with all
the [__]
[__] ali is doing it
ali is doing it he ain't walking around
with a picture of martin luther king
he's just doing it
i don't mean to insult you anything like
that you're just doing it
you're just doing it for you your family
and for [__] comedy so
you're a [__] animal brother
i'm trying to be the best
the best me i can actually be you know
everybody gonna do what they gonna do
man and
in this business
it's like swimming i never thought that
comedy was like swimming
and swimming you just trying to beat
the last time you swam this race like
hey what was my last time
okay this time i'm gonna try to beat
that time by seconds
so in comedy
i'm just trying to i'm just racing
myself i'm just having fun talking and
this the type of freedom
that you that i said around and i
dreamed about just having
doing what i actually want like some
people say they do i do what i want to
do but then when i go to work like
you don't do what you want to do like i
actually do
what i want to do is if if i want to get
up and go to costa rica i'm going
if i if i want to sit up if i want to
sleep all day i'm sleeping
and there's no
consequence to it it's just
what what what better job what better
life what better way to celebrate
and and release yourself from that
prison thing like every
i used to try to i used to try to
[Music]
remember so i wouldn't forget
remember
so i wouldn't forget to make those
mistakes
i don't have to do any of it no more i'm
just not in a mistake
filled
position why me with those with those
type of risk even come up anymore i
don't even have to think about
oh remember prison so you won't do this
tonight
i'm like
what am i what's gonna happen i'm like a
white kid in the grocery store man i'm
like i do whatever i wanna do
hey i'm i'm eating cookies
i'm not stealing what's happening what's
going on you know on the other hand i
don't want people to watch this and hey
well i want to live my life
like ali well i gotta i gotta remind
[__] of this before you can
live your life with that freedom
you gotta put the work in to deserve
that freedom you know
you were talking about comedy is like
swimming let me tell you something life
every monday you got a second chance
as far as i'm concerned
you [__] up last week you ate a cookie
you know you [__] up your diet
you did coke with that [__]
blonde chick you know you're [__] up
there we all [__] up
mondays is a second chance
to [__] do it all over again i don't
give a [__] if you got a [__] up 200
times i was telling somebody something
that with acupuncture they used to
always put a needle in my ear before i
left an addiction on this side it's for
addiction and my job was to make that
[__] fly out of my ear by
snorting coke i would just do lines of
coke until the [__] just went
pop like a skyrocket like a bottle rock
and shot out of my [__] ear
it didn't matter i was still [__]
sticking that thing in my ear every
goddamn tuesday and eventually one of
those tuesdays it caught
and i'm here i'm not doing coke anymore
because i had two prisons brother i had
regular prison and then i put my prison
i put my life in the prison of addiction
which is worse than the prison of
[__] them putting four walls around
you and telling you when you have to
shower
the prisoner of addiction is a
[__] and a lot of people can't
jump that fence
so
once you beat through those things which
you put listen nobody puts you in jail
when you go to jail you meet 20
[__] and locked in that didn't
do anything
they haven't crossed the street they
said i robbed the shop right i haven't
been in shot all right
nobody ever does anything but
that's what i love that every monday as
human beings we got another shot
no matter what happened last week you
got a whole new set of rules
a whole new set of priority you know
what i tried being gay last week i want
to do it this week i'm just going to be
a training
you know this week i'm just going to put
eyelashes on and scotch tape my dick to
my blood sack and give it a shot
but you're [__] pushing you're making
your life happen and that's all that
[__] matters that people forgot
people have forgotten this [__]
that's the analogy
that's the analogy that you got last
week you wore a dress this week you duct
tape your dick give it a shot because if
you ain't somebody else well they gotta
figure it out before you [__]
it's like don marrero said if you ain't
practicing basketball somebody else is
when you're a basketball player that's
your mentality what time is it two in
the morning some [__] dribble
in that basement right now i better get
in that basement right now
somebody's doing shadow drills at two in
the morning oh my goodness
last week
this time you just take me and johnson
until you're late hey man
take that [__] with some kmart
duct tape your dick ain't going nowhere
jack
that k-mart duct tape the [__] the
cubans use on cars in cuba you can hit a
[__] tank with your dick oh them
cubans they do [__] with duct tape
hey duct tape is
the real gorilla glue like
i think really cool melted down duct
tape because whatever is on the inside
of duct tape my man good luck i got duct
taped by some columbians one time
man you know that eyebrow my eyebrow was
never like that this
this whole eyebrow came off
it looked like it was like i had
leukemia man for years i mean i had one
i mean it was crazy they was wrong for
that [__]
dawg i duct taped the dude one time
that was it you're wrong it wasn't my
idea i was just telling somebody last
night it was in 93.
i teamed up with a dude he's dead now
god rest his soul is my brother this
dude believed in my comedy this dude
shot people
hit people with sticks but then he drove
me to my gigs and he wanted me to be
there on time and he'd tell me not to
curse on stage you want to be clean bro
and then he [__] leave me and go get
a grammar blow and come back this guy
was a savage
but one day he's like let's chase some
[__] dominicans up in harlem
this [__] just threw the coke
out of the car and ran away he just
pulled we followed him for two days
we're snorting coke following this dude
and then we caught him we duct taped him
we made sure the coke was coke and then
we just left him there duct taped
he's probably in cuba right now he's
probably in colombia right now as we
speak cutting that duck now he was
dominican
long time ago 93.
yo they say the crazy thing is that you
ran with somebody who hit somebody with
a stick do you know
i don't think i don't think i don't
think people understand because because
being in the world
of crime
a stick to hit somebody with a stick i
need people i don't have people with axe
handles
with louisville sluggers i'll hit people
with a small bat
but to find a stick sturdy enough
to hit somebody with and and hit him
that's a bad that's a that's a that's a
real dude and i haven't seen it i
haven't seen him before i didn't see
somebody have a stick and whoop the [__]
out of somebody with himself like god
damn that [__] rugged
[Music]
i'm gonna tell you who could move with a
stick more than anybody i wasn't my
mother
my mother would turn that broom handle
upside down and take the broom side off
one time she crashed a pool party
because i didn't make my bed
she crashed a [__] pool party with a
stick dog and started yelling in spanish
and i'm in the pool with white kids i'm
yelling who's this crazy spanish woman
call 9-1-1
she's like 9-1-1 [__] you're
dead
she chased me with that stick hit me
with it she could [__] swing a broom
handle i must have got hit with 20
[__] broom handles in my day little
ones big ones
then she used the thing like a [__]
gladiator and poked me in the side so
they didn't [__]
oh yeah my mom was no joke guys i don't
you know these little [__] today have
no idea my mom used to gladiator me once
a [__] month with that [__] you
know she hit me with the cross sword and
then when you bent over she'd give me
the [__] gladiator i forgot about the
poke man my mom used to poke me with
that bro
i forgot about the jack [__] pulp
you got the
my mother was dimensional she was like
an octopus she could throw a sandal at
you an ashtray
a [__] broomstick or stab you my
mother my mother was good she was good
she had this little chop
she did to the throat like something
it's like it paused you like you you be
talking
and that's what she can get to wherever
she gonna actually get to
like man
my mother clipped me one time i
we didn't have the throat punch we had
the mouth cover the
the [__] quick backhand it's called
the tapawaka
it opens you up
she just gives you the backhand and it
sounds like one of these
but only reverse
you swallow the [__] oxygen you get
all choked up and [__] from the backhand
moms could [__] hit all of the 70s
and 80s moms were [__] swinging for
the fences now that's why these kids are
shooting [__] schools and they're
[__] up
because moms ain't hitting them in their
head you know
again we spoke about it yesterday how
this texas thing is awake call for
parents
in every [__] dimension this we got
to start watching our kids a little bit
[__] more
you know they can't be [__] wearing
skirts and shooting you know
there's just a lot of signs what are the
signs of your kids going [__]
[__] a lot
because i was one of those [__] kids
i just never wanted to shoot the [__]
school up yeah that's that's the crazy
part i never wanted to shoot i didn't
want to hurt my friends for any [__]
reason at all
why i heard other kids like i never i
never
i never understood that part
and because i never i never wanted to do
it i hey i want to beat up mr johnson i
i hate this principle
and and i hated them
because i was doing [__] like it's like
it's not like guess guess who wasn't
guess who didn't hate him the mass
majority of the school didn't hate him
because they wasn't doing [__]
and then
the only people who hate you and that
hates school are people who doing [__]
in school
that's not school [__] when i was
involved in school stuff i love school i
love school
when i was old at school
so i loved it i loved going to school
selling some reefer a couple hits of
masculine
[__] i saw schoolers
30 credits and [__] 200 a week you
know when i went to school i went to
school to eat and [__] smoke pot and
see my friends and study i loved it
but i could my daughter i look at my
daughter dog she loves school you know
why because it's a little social [__]
hour
she loves going into that [__] school
i couldn't pay her to stay home from
school
i'll tell her sometimes [__] i'll
give you 50 bucks let's say
dad i gotta go to school
and i was the same way i mean i went to
school and played hooky
if i went to school and we saw a beer
truck and we robbed that [__]
i was up there i didn't go to school but
i went to school for an excitement i
went to school for action it was like
anything could happen it was like being
on the mickey mouse club on wednesday
anything could happen today i'm going to
school next thing you know we had it to
get pink floyd tickets next you know
we're going into the city to get
tickets or going into the city to see a
peep show
you know sometimes in the 8th grade you
want to see some [__] you can't be
looking at those playboys and cherry
cherry and pikapika you got to go in
there and get you got to go in there see
it for yourself and smell it i'm saying
um
yeah
school was that for me like i i didn't
know where it was gonna take me man
and then and when i was a kid i didn't
want to hurt other kids our job wasn't
even to hurt teachers was to [__] with
them like in the fifth grade
they gave my teacher had acid
in his coffee he never came back after
lunch you know
[__] like that that's harmless that
[__] is okay today he's probably
old you don't know if that man is okay
that man probably jumped off the empire
state building he came back to school
the next day and looked everybody
suspiciously i'm saying he always had a
suspicious look on his face after that
and [__] even when he taught history
that's what you do that's fun you steal
the frogs
from biology class i used to take all
the frogs and put them in a bag and the
teacher was like where's the frogs i
don't know they're gone they jumped out
i don't [__] know then we robbed the
scales from the school because we
started selling drugs
so you couldn't weigh a [__] nail in
my school we took every [__] triple
beam there was
every triple beam there was in north
bergen high we stole one night they came
to my house the next day joey give us
back the scales we know it was you
well i sold five of them all right give
us back [__] six like keep an extra
one but don't do it again
yeah we just stole the scales yeah we
weren't [__] around it was never i
don't do we never gotta don't do it
again we got we was on trial like
i didn't even do this my man snatched
the person i was in the car i didn't
even know and they came to the school
i don't even know how to even saw
anybody in the car
they questioned us about a person
and they and they i wasn't even guilty
and he was like yo it was like i was a
leper at the school
like like
you are criminal
you have criminal behavior criminal
tendencies like yo man
i i was in the car i didn't even know
that man was snatching a purse
like well i don't smash purses you're
coining it's corny
but
they it was no second chance it's like i
was from that point on i was like a
troublemaker to them i'm like no i'm not
i was in a car with a
dude who was trying to prove that he was
black
by smashing the purge that's not how you
do it like
what about marching goddamn we did that
too
this way like man
i should i should have i should have
been on i should have been more on the
debate team
[Music]
i would have been a good debater
i don't know what i just wanted to go to
school
and get a [__] diploma i didn't know
what was gonna i ended up waiting school
my senior year because my my i hadn't
have anybody around and uh i had to put
my [__] skills to the test
but it's [__] weird that we got this
far
high school diploma i'd be dead man it
don't it don't sound like you went to
school to get a diploma it did the
description that you gave me the
diploma
like you don't sound like the stealing
the frogs selling dope stealing the
trooper no that sounds like you wanted
to graduate it's all a part of the
curriculum
when i grew up it was all part of a
curriculum that's why
we made up the way we did the curriculum
was a little deeper you know these kids
don't do dick you know part of the
curriculum was delivering newspapers ali
part of the curriculum was uh
helping your neighbors with groceries
and [__] for the small quarter
half of the curriculum there was a lot
in that curriculum
so there was a lot of good
physics
and there was a yes and there was a lot
of and that curriculum today is what
children need because there's no
children have no more social skills they
don't know how to do anything on their
own
school it was it was class
hey
joy get up here
and show them
how you communicate when someone
owes you money
now you see
you see how he did that
that's how life goes
it was that you're gonna have to hold
people up
joe
on this on this day we doing triple
babes anyone's got one by chance i do
as a matter of fact i do remember belly
the belly sales is the biggest gift you
could have
if you don't know how to sell you're
going to have a rough reserve
yeah so they don't teach kids that
that's what we learned by delivering
papers
by upgrading people by shoveling snow
for people by when it snowed who the
[__] we went and pushed people in cars
and you made an extra 20 dollars
you know there was listen there was a
lot of good you know again i remember
going to church and selling the [__]
boosters so people could put in their
house
and put in the window i would sell it to
them for a dollar and steal it back the
next day that teaches you how to hustle
that teaches you how to [__] you know
you know recycle
you know when you play baseball on the
street you break a window
the people come out you got to sit with
at first you run because you're a scared
little [__] but then your parents say
you got to go back out there and talk to
these people and figure out a payment
plan and how you got to pay back the
window
these were all little parts of growing
up that children
are not seen today
and this is why our children have the
deficiencies that do they do my
curriculum was a little [__] [__]
up
but it paid for itself years later
hey mrs johnson i have an apple for you
and
glad
does anyone see my apple
are you looking at me [__]
i'm talking about getting you to apple
it's already gone but think about all
this [__] you learned by being bad that
now oh you're using a good way for your
[__] comedy crazy you use it it's
[__] crazy so
this is why i say sometimes
you gotta
listen just
to open up your mind to a child to open
up your mind to anybody the other day i
had to tell him mike my daughter played
and the catcher caught a foul ball my
daughter looked at me and said i didn't
know you could do that they just opened
up their mind
by opening up your mind a little bit
they'll teach them other things you know
even if it is negative like i used to
[__] rob beer trucks
and one day on the way to school we saw
a beer truck pulled over
and we robbed a beer truck it was it was
a case of michelob nips i got a case of
michelob nips
well they happen to fit in the [__]
locker
so i put it in the locker okay so i did
something bad
but then mr lee at the time was like a
vice principal he came to me he's like
open up your locker the cops say and
they go
ah
[__]
i learned business law you need a
warrant to get into that [__] locker
[__] sucker
and i broke it down to him and i sold
him on it to the fact
that i had done something bad but
something good had come out of it
because then i asserted my business law
education
and the [__] could not come in
my lock and the cop even looked at me
goes he's got us here you got to go to a
judge and get a [__] warrant and
start this removal i became like law and
order
i was like low in order all of a sudden
when i was a sophomore so
something bad
led me to something good led you to test
your knowledge i made my [__]
point you understand me that
you got to get a warrant like jay-z said
you got to get a warrant if you want to
go in this [__]
in this glove compartment did they leave
a cop there and no
[__] no they [__] left me alone
and that teacher didn't talk to me until
five years later in 83 when i tried to
bust into a bookie's house and the dog
chased me and i ripped my hand open
here's the scar right here
and i went to the high school and he
goes why are you bleeding and i go
because i got caught on the fence a dog
was chasing me
and listen to this sadiq this is only
[__] that you and i will ever judge in
our lives
the guy was looking at my we did not
have a talk for five years we didn't
look at each other
he opened up my hand and he goes listen
you didn't get stitches you're not gonna
have
movement
he goes but if i put a toilet roll and
close your hand and do it you'll be okay
as he was doing it he goes somebody
asked me the other day if i ever treated
somebody i didn't like
i didn't know how to answer them and
then you walked in
and do you know that we went from hating
each other to [__] i went to colorado
and i would call him every week and
check up on mr lee i even sent flowers
when he died his wife even called me and
said he was very fond of you
i said yeah the first five years of our
lives we [__] hated each other but
that's
the scott man the scars i was thinking
about
doing uh a show
i'm just talking about talking to people
about how they
got a certain skull
like you know i know i i know how i got
this lit
in my face
i know i i i know i got it
he was like well how that load that's
the little scar that's very significant
that's a that's the tip of a butcher
knife
james garcia slit me in the face
i'm like [__]
damn my [__] blade like a
[__]
yeah oh my goodness right but like the
whole if the whole thing would have
caught me i'd had it across the face but
the tip of it caught right when i moved
back
and i was like
and people talk about how they got
certain scars
i have a skull on my knee where it
looked like a j
but remember the old the old um
[Music]
curtain rods they they would connect and
they would come they would come on loose
and it was like this little handlebar
and he said that
j at the end to hold it yeah how they
connected
and
my sister threw one
and hit me in the leg and then and and
it left and it stuck in my leg and then
left that
jab i got the leg
a little
it's like russians have the tattoos
to tell a story of their life we don't
need it
yeah
we don't [__] need it you robbed a
beard truck and that's how you got this
star in your head that's [__] crazy
that was possibly the longest fart
oh my god it's terrible
it's a protein fought it had to be how
long was it mike
10 seconds that thing it was like a drum
roll and [__] that came out of my ass
you didn't hear it dolly
i heard something i thought you were
moving the seat no that was the my
[__] moving the [__] seat you
understand me that [__] was
pushing the gauge i'm surprised mike
didn't pass the [__] out here that's a
good [__] protein fart but anyway
so the name of the special is what
because i'm about to pass out that fart
went straight up into the microphone you
should be getting about 3.2 seconds
yeah you see a little cloud of smoke and
[__] like a little baby afro on gi joe
it's just gonna go poof that's it
mike are you okay mike he's all right
he's he's sitting down with an ice pack
on his eyeball and [__] that
oh my god that was horrible that protein
powder i don't know what the [__] they
put in that [__]
but sometimes you fart and you're like
why eat something healthy if my
asshole's gonna smell like that i'd
rather
i might as well eat a white castle my
asshole's gonna smell like that
eating [__] cheese and broccoli and
apples and what comes out of your ass is
this green hornet mist
chinese people and [__] what's the name
of the album that's coming out the
special is the domino effect
and when does that get released
it is out right now came out may 19th
the album is coming out
after this which is um the next
right what i think is
june 19th yeah father's day the album is
coming out yeah and that's apple
um
yeah i think that's my website
it's on my website okay just on
inside deep.com
um yeah alistik.com because you know
these these streaming companies having
the time right now with
people suing them and they you know they
going through a lot so
you gotta you gotta try to figure out
ways to resist it yourself to until they
come back on and then you you license it
out to them for a second but man
it's rough
hey make sure y'all go check out the
domino effect that's on youtube right
now for free
share tell a friend tell a friend cuz
you gonna love it i'll have to even say
if you like it because you're gonna love
it if you like storytelling this is the
ultimate
um
check it out man i sure appreciate you
having me on man
ali i always got you i always got you
because uh what you're doing is a
beautiful thing you're doing a lot more
than comedy
you're giving brothers a chance to look
at you and say you know what i'm gonna
do that
and that's the biggest gift you could
give to humanity man so
i love you to that that's what this
podcast is about letting these
[__] know that there's a second
chance and if you really want it it's or
it's in your [__] favor
don't they say it's a it's a seller's
market it's a
dog 24 7 since the beginning of time
it's a it's all about you and if you
really want it no matter what the [__]
coat they want to put on you
alissa deek is living [__] proof
a brother with [__] felonies and
still slinging dick like moses malone in
19 [__] 80 when i went to see him and
he was [__] grabbing 32 24 rebounds a
game you know what i'm saying
i always got to take it back to moses
far far forward he [__] swept those
[__] in 83.
that's what they're not going to tell
you in winning with the lakers and [__]
yeah they beat the sixers but sixes went
and regrouped and they came back with
moses and the promised land and that was
it
julius went off in 83. yeah every time
he played against magic magic would get
hurt and [__] his hamstring
he'd hold on to his face [__] you
truly a serving time [__] i love
you ali stay black
and uh these guys will be looking out
for your album release
thank you brother very much all right i
love you guys
keep doing what you're doing brother
all right i want to thank alisa dick
i want to thank big mike for being here
but most importantly i want to thank you
savages
for always having my back
the joint is also brought to you by
manscape
listen it's [__] june and we're going
over this you ever reach down and your
balls smell like newark
it's time to get the platinum package
from manscape joey what's a platinum
package it's the lawnmower 4.0 with a
special blade so you don't nick your
[__] nut sack and the spotlights you
could shave in the dark if you're into
it and if you're in the shower shaving
in the dark it's waterproof
the weed whacking nose and head trimmer
comes in there too to keep your ears and
your nose clean and the crop preserver
crop reviver
to creep keep the [__] south clean
down there and your nut your nut sack
your [__] pointing the whole thing
nice and clean tilt the premium
collection with body wash two in one
shampoo conditioner and deodorant and
they're gonna throw in some [__]
some moisturizer for your lips just in
case you decide to switch governments
you know what i'm saying medscape get 20
off plus free shipping with code joey at
manscape.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with code joey at manscape.com
listen your balls will thank you and the
joint is also brought to you by
cbd line when it comes to the best cbd
in the market it's cbd line how do i
know how the [__] do i know anything i
lived it [__] whether you use the
cream the roll-up
ball
the [__]
kinesiology tape whether you want to
just take [__] cb uh cbd orally with
the gel caps listen
cbd lion will narrow it down for you
help you get the party started so go to
cbdline.com right now preston joey and
get 20 off i want to thank manscape
cbd lion
lucy.col
[__] bluechu
best spoke post and liquid iv for having
my back and for having your back i'll
see you [__] monday morning tip
top magoo stay black